Transcription: Tana Silverland
Relecteur: eric vautier
Mesdemoiselles, mesdames
et messieurs, bonsoir !
Je suis Docteur Yeo.
Je suis en charge
des questions d’industrialisation
et des études prospectives
au Conseil du Café-Cacao.
Alors
Bienvenue au pays
du cacao.
Notre chère patrie la Côte d'Ivoire.
Aujourd’hui,
le thème que je veux
vous présenter porte sur
la problématique de la transformation
du cacao pour transformer nos vies.
De quoi s’agit-il ?
Voici un pays comme la Côte d’Ivoire,
qui
a tiré 40 % de ses recettes
d’exportation de la culture du cacao.
Et qui en même temps
produit 40 %
de tout le cacao au niveau mondial.
Nous avons été amenés à faire un constat :
avec
la place qu’occupe donc le cacao
dans la vie de la Côte d’Ivoire,
le constat que nous faisons, c’est
qu’aujourd’hui, moins de 6% des revenus
qui sont générés par cette culture-là,
reviennent aux pays producteurs.
Je n’ai pas dit « revient à
la Côte d’Ivoire », aux pays producteurs.
C'est quand même un constat choquant.
Et ce choc-là va mener
les présidents
des deux premiers pays producteurs
que sont la Côte d’Ivoire et le Ghana,
en mars 2018,
à opter pour plus de transformation
parce qu’effectivement,
ils ont compris que c’est par la
transformation qu’ils prendront
une part plus importante du gâteau.
Nous parlons de 6 % des revenus
issus de la chaîne de production du cacao.
Comment est-ce que cette chaîne
de valeur du cacao se présente ?
J’ai essayé de caricaturer sur
la chaîne de valeur du cacao,
en deux chemins dans le même graphique,
mais qui ramène, pratiquement,
que ce soit l’un ou l’autre,
qui ramène pratiquement
à la même situation.
Sauf que les acteurs, parfois,
peuvent changer.
Vous avez un premier chemin où ce sont
des coopératives de producteurs
qui vont collecter les produits du cacao
dont je veux parler,
fermenté, séché,
comme il est attendu des broyeurs.
Ce cacao collecté auprès des producteurs
va donc être porté aux exportateurs
ou encore auprès des acheteurs.
Et à partir de là,
il est convoyé de l’autre côté vers
un autre acteur que nous appelons
la contrepartie.
Cette contrepartie peut être
parfois des négociants
ou encore des industriels.
Le second chemin que vous avez
fait intervenir un autre acteur
dont je n’avais pas parlé plus haut,
ce sont les pisteurs.
Les pisteurs, qui apparaissent dans la
chaîne de valeur,
vont travailler pour le compte
des acheteurs.
Ils collectent, donc, à la
place des coopératives de cacao.
Et ils le font pour le compte des
acheteurs qui le portent aux exportateurs.
Et là, on voit un autre acteur qui
apparaît, c’est le transformateur.
Mais une fois le cacao est
à la main des exportateurs,
le schéma présenté précédemment s’observe,
il est toujours porté soit à
un négociant ou un industriel
dans la contrepartie
que nous avons indiquée.
Lorsqu’il s’agit du transformateur, vous
avez des transformateurs de niveau 1, 2
qui sont installés
sur le territoire ivoirien.
Ceux-là, pour la majeure
partie d’entre eux,
se contentent de broyer le cacao.
Et au besoin, de sortir
du beurre de cacao, de sortir du toto
et parfois la peau comestible du cacao.
Ça, c’est le chemin ordinaire
que nous observons.
Alors,
en continuant d’observer cette situation,
on se pose une question tout de suite.
Comment la Côte d’Ivoire est-elle arrivée
au stade de premier broyeur mondial ?
J’espère que dans cette salle,
on avait l’information
que la Côte d’Ivoire était
premier producteur.
Maintenant, vous savez qu'on est
aussi premier transformateur.
Je dirais que cela fait partie
du choc qu’on a vu.
Qu’on observe que pour un pays
qui tire 40% de ses recettes
d’exportation d’une culture,
un pays qui constate qu’à lui seul,
il produit 40% de la production mondiale.
Ce pays-là a le cartes
pour fixer un objectif clair.
Après la rencontre
des deux chefs d’Etat en 2018,
l’objectif de transformer 50%
de notre production va être fixé.
Mais c’est un objectif qui n’aura de sens
que s’il est soutenu par des politiques.
Et les politiques ici, ce sont des
politiques d’incitation fiscale
qui ont été mises en place, en tout cas,
c’est l’option de la Côte d’Ivoire.
La matérialisation de cette politique
d'incitation fiscale est l'instauration
d’un droit unique de sortie différencié.
Je vais vous expliquer un peu
en quoi consiste ce droit unique
de sortie différenciée.
Il existe déjà le droit unique de sortie
qui s’applique à tous les produits
qui sortent du pays.
Mais dans le cas des produits
issus de la transformation,
ce droit unique de sortie a été appelé
différencié
parce qu’il donne des avantages et des
possibilités selon le niveau d’ouvraison.
Il est prévu des exonérations.
Juste pour quelqu’un qui ne fait aucune
transformation sur la fève,
le droit unique de sortie
est fixée à 14,6 %.
Et en fonction de votre niveau d’ouvraison
et du volume transformé,
vous pouvez vous retrouver
à zéro pour cent.
Et ça, c’est le cadeau qui est fait à tous
ceux qui vont jusqu’au chocolat.
Je veux oser parler un peu des différents
pourcentages intermédiaires.
Quand vous avez un tel taux -
Il existe aussi en plus
dans la même politique fiscale
des incitations fiscales, des exonérations
qui portent sur les équipements,
sur les droits de douane et sur la TVA.
On va dire que tout investisseur qui
choisit la destination Côte d’Ivoire
va se voir exonéré de la TVA sur
l’ensemble du matériel qu’il importe
pour l’implantation de son unité
de transformation.
Également, les droits de douane
ici seront exonérés
sur les différents équipements
qui viennent pour l’usine.
Mais cela est assorti d'une convention
que vous signez au niveau du CPC.
Il s'agit d'en faire la demande.
Aujourd’hui, quand on a fini de présenter
cette Côte d’Ivoire
qui a été le premier producteur, ensuite
le premier transformateur,
parce qu’elle s’est donnée
une politique suffisamment bonne
pour attirer les investisseurs,
nous regardons vers le futur.
Qu’est-ce qu’il reste à faire pour nous
assurer que l’objectif qu’on s’est fixé
sera maintenu,
vu que les résultats
sont déjà visibles à partir de la
politique fiscale d’exonération ?
Nous pensons à l’implantation
d’unités de transformation
de moindre capacité.
Aujourd’hui, la transformation
dont je vous parlais porte
sur les multinationales qui ont des
grosses usines de transformation.
Nous pensons qu’avec une transformation
de niveau moyen,
on peut cibler déjà les nationaux
qui veulent atteindre un certain
niveau de transformation
et qui n’ont pas forcément
de grands moyens.
Ensuite il y a la technologie de la
transformation à petite échelle
qu’il faut encourager.
Là, vous ciblez un coopérative.
Déjà, au niveau de chaque coopérative,
les producteurs eux-mêmes sont capables,
avec des petites technologies, de pouvoir
transformer une partie de leur production.
Ainsi, ils captureront directement
de la valeur ajoutée
et ils pourront mieux apprécier
le fruit de leurs efforts.
Et comme nous ne voulons pas
seulement nous contenter
de la petite transformation
et de la moyenne transformation,
nous proposons également
qu’il y ait un coup d’accélérateur
qui soit donné pour que nous puissions
atteindre la grande transformation,
celle qui est faite aujourd’hui
par les multinationals.
À ce niveau,
l’intervention de l’Etat est attendue.
Nous attendons ici de l’Etat
qu’on crée des unités de transformation
propres à la Côte d’Ivoire,
ce qui a commencé.
Il y a quelques mois de cela,
le chef de l’Etat a lancé les travaux de
la construction de deux usines de cacao.
L’une sera à PK24 à Abidjan
et l’autre à San Pedro.
Ce modèle d’unités de transformation
ne vise pas
pour autant, à prendre la place du privé.
Il s’agit de développer un savoir-faire,
d’attirer des nationaux
vers ce savoir-faire,
et ensuite d’ouvrir le capital
aux sociétés privées,
qui vont progressivement récupérer
dans cette transformation
du niveau qui est souhaitable.
C’est sur ces points que nous voulons
nous arrêter pour vous dire merci,
merci pour le petit voyage qu’on vient
de faire au pays du cacao.
(Applaudissements)